あの大変難しいテーマで
皆様のまあ最終回になりましたけど
大変忍耐強く辛抱強く聞いていただきまして
また最終回にもいらっしゃる
本当にどうもありがとうございます
で あの まあ日本語で悟りという言葉について話してきましたけど
結局私はまあ悟りということよりは
パーリ経典にあるこの涅槃という言葉に基ついて話を進めていきました
えーと まあ仏教という仏教はお釈迦様の教えというのは
この解脱することを悟ることを目的としていますので
まあいろんな角度で いろんな形で
いろんな言葉で まあ解脱ということに人々を励まして方法を教えていますから
どこまで喋ったっても終わらないほどたくさんいろんな教えがあります
で とにかくその中でいくらかこの思い浮かぶポイント
いくらかお話しさせていただけただけであって
それはすべてということではありません
そういうことで このまた皆様方
経典なんかをお読みになると
またいろんな角度でお釈迦様は解脱と涅槃ということを説明しているところをお目にかかると思います
で あの 日本語でまあ悟りというと
まあどういうことかとはっきりしない場合もあります
あの まあまとめて言えば
何かありがたいことだと
まあそれぐらいでしょうと思います
明確に説明理解といえば
やっぱりいろいろ意味があるんですね
悟りって何でしょうかと
もうそれはもうあまり日本語の悟りという言葉にしてもはっきりしないんです
宗教 仏教の世界になってくると
あ これはまあ仏教の大変ありがたいもうことですよぐらいにしか理解はないと思いますけど
でもあの この仏教から
またこの悟りという漢字から
まあまあ悟ることですから
その言葉をきっかけにして
仏教における悟りという涅槃という解脱という概念を説明することも不可能ではありません
ただ 一般的な日本語で悟るということは
何か目覚めるということなんですね
いわゆる何かを発見すると
今までわからなかったこと
今まで自分には隠して隠されてあったことにパッと目が覚めたと
いわゆるあ わかりましたと
そういう意味でも 仏教における悟りということは説明はできるんです
それで そのどのように説明するかというと
やっぱりお釈迦様がおっしゃったこの真理というものがございまして
それはお釈迦様は最初からもうみんなよくわかるものという気持ちでお話をしたわけじゃないんです
この真理はとても一般の人々にとっては一番わかりにくい
理解しにくいものだと
ですから 理解しないこと
わかってくれないこと
それはもう前提として
当たり前として知った上で説法しているんですね
そこをいくらか理解すると
悟りの方向へ行けるんです
今日言いたいのは 例えば真理として
お釈迦様は世の中の真理なんでしょうか
という場合は もう簡単にすべては無常であると
全てはドゥッカ 苦しみであると
全ては実体のないものであると
いわゆる幻覚のようなものであると
私は使う言葉は現象であると
あるいは空であると思っても構いません
そうすると私たちはなんとなくわかったような気がするんですね
無常ですよと言ったら
わかりましたと 無常ですよ
当たり前ですよと そのよくわかってくれることは一番問題で
失礼な言葉で言えば それだけは一番迷惑なんですね
全てのことは無常でありますよと
そんな早くわかってほしくないんです
だから お釈迦様の立場から言えば
一切は無常であるとおっしゃっても
聞いている側がわからないのは
理解しないのは普通であって
理解したんだと言ったら
なんかちょっとどうかなと
だから私たちも もし仏教で教えている解脱と涅槃
悟りということを理解したいと思うならば
最初からもうこの無常ということをね
そんな簡単にわかるわけではありませんと
と覚えた方がいいんです
それでまあわかりやすいんですから
無常という言葉に縛ります
絞りますけど 我々の経験では
いくらか世の中のことはまあ無常であるということはいくらかはわかってます
そのわかっているところは頭の頭だけなんですね
うわべだけなんですね
本心でではわかってないんです
例えばもう ちょっとあの地面が揺れて窓ガラスを割れたとする
それは無常だから当たり前のことなんですね
でも心の中で認めたくないんですね
大変だと どうしようかと
これ修理するのは大変だと
で 困ったり悩んだりする
それよりもっともっと例を同じ例を変えちゃうと
道路で遊んでいる子供は石一個持ってもう殴っ
まあ投げてしまったと
それで自分の部屋 家にあった一番大きな窓ガラスを割れてしまったと
ケロッとしていることはできないんですね
何事も起こらなかったような感じでいることはできないんですね
いきなり心の中に怒ってしまうんですね
怒ってしまって それからいろいろ行動してしまっちゃうんですね
その子供を誰か調べたりとか
あるいは子供を叱ったりとか
あるいはその子供の親を親に弁償しなさいと
もし向こう側が断ったら
そんなこと知りませんと
責任持てませんと 子供っていうのはあっちこっち行ったり遊んだりするんだけど
ずっとまあ学校からうちに帰るまででも親が責任を持つべきですか？ともし言ったならばどうなるんでしょうか
さらにこれはもう続けて行っちゃうんですね
学校にまで行って訴えるかもしれません
それ学校も責任持ちませんと
学校から出たらと言ったら
まあどんどん心が怒りやらいろんな悲しみでいっぱいになっちゃうんですね
じゃあ我々は無常をわかっているのであるならば
そうなるはずがないんですね
ですから無常ですよ まあそれぐらいはわかりますよと
お釈迦様はもう何のことない
簡単なことを教えているんだと
と言うんですけど あまり難しくはないんだと
そんな話は 時々こういうふうに言うんです
それは頭の悪いお坊さんたちに言ってる話ですよと
もっとすごいことをお釈迦様仏教でありますよとそこまで言う場合もあります
でも まあお釈迦様の立場から言えばわかってないと
わからないのは当たり前なんですね
ただ単に無常ということさえ
突然病院に検査に行ったところで
自分が気がつかないのにも関わらず
何か大変重い病気を発見したりする
いろいろ病気ありますね
治療できない病気 それでどうなるんですかね
すぐもう頭がおかしくなってしまうんですね
混乱してしまうんですね
認めたくはなくなっちゃうんですね
あれは何でしょうかね
そこでその人に聞いたら
あんた人は病気になるということは認めませんか？と聞いたら
とんでもない 人間だったら病気になりますよと
で 偉そうなことを言うんです
で なんで今あなたはすごく混乱しているんですかと聞いてみたら
そういうことをちょっと考えていただきたいんですね
だからなぜ人間が苦しんだり悩んだりしますかというと
無常を否定しているんだからなんです
すべての物事は無常であると
それははっきりした事実なんですが
それは徹底的に否定する
だからどれぐらい否定するかと
それぐらい並ならぬ苦しみを味わえなくてはならないのです
ほんのちょっと この学校で学んだほんのちょっとのこの知識のからくりで何か理解したような気がする
錯覚するだけ だから無常ですよと言っても
当たり前のことを言ってはいけませんと
いうような顔をするんですね
そういう顔をするんだけど
問題は解決していないんですね
そういうわけでお釈迦様が言うのは
すべての物事は現象は無常である
それは智慧でもってわかる人にとっては
すべての苦しみが消えてしまうんだと
何の苦しみもその人にとっては存在しないんだと
ですから無常ですよとわかることは
すなわち悟りなんです
ですから それぐらいのことはわかってますよというならば
逆にじゃああなたは悟ってますかと質問すればいいのです
それでこの仏教を勉強している真面目な人々というのは
まあ頭ではわかっているんだけど
本当は理解していないんだと
この悟るということは
その無常に悟ることなんですね
逆に言えば逆ではなくて
違う言葉で言い換えれば
自分の心に悟るんです
無常を否定する自分のアホらしさに悟るんですね
なんというアホかと自分が
すべて無常なのに その自分のアホらしさに悟ることは無明をなくすという言葉で
違う用語でお釈迦様はおっしゃっているんですね
アウィッジャですね 無明
無知を破ると 違う言葉で言えば無常に悟ると
心の立場から言えば無明を破ると
だからこれは頭だけで考えると決して不可能なことではありません
これは決まっている 遠い昔いた何人かの人々にだけできたものですよと
そういうものじゃないんです
もう少し考えると 無常であることは十分もう心の中からもひらめてもらう
悟ってもらう 理解してもらうではないんです
で そこで悟りというものは成立して成り立つんです
ですから 仏教における悟りっていうのは
決してある一つの観念
ちょっとした概念ではないんです
それはもうはっきりした人間に体験できる一つの体験経験なんです
それで自分が本当に無常をわかったかないかと本人が知ってるんです
なぜならば 自分にはわずかな苦しみも存在しないんです
例えば悟った人が随分体が病気になっても
ものすごい苦しんでいるんだと
でもあんた苦しんでるんで
まあ体は苦しいんだけど
だから何ですかと まあボロボロだからそれは当たり前ですよと
全然そこを精神的に何の問題もないんです
でも普通の人はそうじゃないんですね
年取って体が弱くなって痛くなってくると
まあ朝から晩までずっと文句言ってるんですね
腰が痛いと もう膝が痛いと
もうご飯あまり食べられないと
食欲はないと 目が見えませんと
耳が遠くなったと 血圧は高いんだと
もういろいろいろいろ言うんですね
だから言うのはいいんだけど
もう精神的にはものすごく悩んだり
苦しんだり 怖くなったりする
死を近寄ってくると もう怯えて怯えて
もうすごい怯えるんですね
だからすごく優しい人が
どんどん年取って病気になってくると
いきなりすごいわがままになって
頑固になって 突然性格まで変わってしまっちゃうでしょ
人の言うことは聞かない
みんなにも言いたい放題文句を言う
大変きつい性格になってしまっちゃうんですね
それなぜそうなりますかと
そこはやっぱりこの変化していくんだということ
自分が消えていくんだと死んでいくんだということは認めたくはないんですから
なんです ですから まあじゃあ悟った人は病気にならないかと
大体この宗教は売り物にするんだったら
そういう風に喋った方が随分売れるんです
悟った人にはもう何の苦しみもない
大変楽しくて幸福ばっかしで
もう病気も何もないんだと
意のままに何でももうコントロールできるんだとか何とかと言ったら
ああ それだったら私も頑張ってみるぞと
それはもう欲そのものであって
無常を否定するそのものなんです
ですから この一般の無知の人々の間では
仏教は人気も人気の宗教にはならないんです
それ結構きつい 厳しい
それであの まあ今日あのいくつかのポイントを申し上げますけど
まずこの無常というポイントから悟りということを説明しますけど
まあそうやってこの頭だけでは無常ですよと
なんか微かに ああそうだ
その通りやという気持ちがあるんですが
心の中では我々は必死になって無常に対立して戦っているんです
ところが 生きるということ
人々の生きるということは
いかに無常避けられますかと
いかに無常に打ち勝てますか？という戦いなんですね
だから完璧に無知な 戦いなんです
だから 俗世間の生き方は無知な生き方だと
解脱する人の生き方は智慧の生き方やって言葉を使っているのはそういうわけなんです
もう正当化しようかなかろうか
それは私には関係ないんです
我々は人が病気になったら必死になってこれは治そうと努力する
まあ努力すれば治る場合も治らない場合もあります
治る場合も それは無常だから治ったんです
無常でなければ病気は治りません
じゃあ治らなかった場合は？それも無常だから治らなかったんです
でお金がなくなっていくと
ものすごくまた怖くなって心配する
それで必死になって頑張る
ずっとあるようなことを考えて
なんか最近聞いたことは
なんか日本は貯金貧乏なんとかっていう言葉を聞いたんだけど
で そうやってなんで貯金する習慣がつきますかと
やっぱり安定して変化しない状態で何かあってほしいんですね
あれも無常に対する戦いなんですね
お金っていうのは止まるもんじゃない
すぐ逃げるものだと じゃあ逃げないようにどうすればいいかと
じゃあ一番簡単な答えは貯金すればいいんですね
で そこをまあ病気なところまでいったら貯金はするんだけど
それは使うことはしないし
後で使うということだから
後っていうのは今日じゃないんだからね
そこでそのまま死んでしまっちゃうということもあるし
我々のすべての努力っていうのは
たとえご飯を食べることにしたっても
それは無常に対してもう頑張って戦っているんです
ご飯食べなかったら死んじゃうでしょうに
ですから わずかな人間の動きであろうとも
全て人間が無常に対しても対立して戦っているんです
だからどんなものも苦しみになって終わっちゃうんです
なぜ夫婦は喧嘩するんですか？結婚して一般的な喧嘩のことで
結婚して次の日喧嘩するということはないでしょう
１週間も喧嘩しませんし
1ヶ月間も喧嘩しませんし
半年間ぐらい経っていると
もういろいろ喧嘩したりするでしょう
あれも無常は嫌だからなんです
だからお互いに結婚した相手がある側面を見て
これでよかったと結婚する
そこで その性格っていうのは一緒にいるとどんどん変わるんです
他人のことをあまり知らない時は
気をつけて いろいろ対応対応する
どんどん知っていると
もう気をつけることはどんどん薄くなっちゃうんですね
そこで自分から見れば
あれ これ違うんじゃないかと
ということを思って そこで喧嘩になるんです
もし結婚式の時の親御さん
そのままでいたならば
まあ男はお婿さんと喧嘩しないだろうと思います
女の人も同じく 結婚時の
あるいは結婚ちょっと前の態度でずっといるんだったら
自分の旦那か もう喧嘩はしないだろうと思いますけどね
だから何 どんな現象を見ても
人間が無常に対して逆らって戦っているんです
それから苦しみが生まれてくるんです
いろいろトラブルが生まれてくるんです
まあ一応あまり長く説明する必要はないんですけど
これはこの 戦ってはいけないとかね
戦いなさいという問題
単純なことじゃないんです
戦いたければどうぞご自由にと
戦いたくなければどうぞご自由に
それはもう我々にとっては関係ない話で
我々が言うのは無知はダメですよと
智慧が育ってくださいと
智慧さえあれば 戦うなりに戦わないなりに
どっちでも別にもう どっちでもいいんです
まあ大体それぐらいの理解で十分でしょうと勝手に考えますけど
で 悟りっていうのは理解しようと思えば
大体そういうふうに理解した方がいいんですね
我々は無常に逆らっているんだと
無常ということに逆らっているんだから
もう生きるということはトラブルだけですよと
もし苦しみが生まれたら
もし悩みが生まれたら
何でしょうかと すぐ自分がその対象を認めてないんです
病気になったと それで悩んだとするならば
病気になった現象は認めていない
ごく普通なことだと認めてないんです
当たり前のことだと 子供が学校に行けなくなったとする
それで自分が悩んだりすると
自分がその現象は認めていないんです
そうあってはならないと
必ずしも学校へ行くべきですよと思っているんだから
そこで苦しみが生まれてくるんですね
そこで人間の頭の中で
このあるべき姿というものがあるんですね
そこからいろいろ基準ができちゃうんですね
あるべき姿はないんです
こうあるべきですよ どうやって自分がこうあるべきですよと決められますかね
そこは矛盾に逆らっているんです
あるべき形はない そこで悪いことは他人にそれ言うんです
世界はこうあるべきです
あなたはこうあるべきです
子供はこうあるべきですと
そんなにもあるべき姿あるんだったら
自分に対しても言ってみてください
自分に対して私はこうあるべきですよと
その時はその矛盾に気づくでしょう
私はこうあるべきですよと自分に言ってみたら
これはいかにバカバカらしいかと
例えば 私は健康であるべきですよと言ったら健康になりますかね
私は長生きするべきですよと言って言っただけで長生きになるんですかね
私は豊かになるべきですよと言ったら豊かになりますか？私はすごい鋭く
頭が鋭く活動する人間になるべきですよと
そのようにあるべきですよと
じゃあそういうふうになりますかね
お手上げでしょう 自分のことになるとどうにもならない
頭が悪く生まれたならば
もう悪いまんまで行なくちゃいけないし
足一本なくなって生まれたら
まあそれで頑張らなくちゃいけないし
目が一つなくて見えなくなって生まれたら
こうあるべき姿ってないんです
これも矛盾だらけで それから人間
いかに面倒くさいことを作るか
なぜ世の中で差別がありますかと
至る所にきめ細かく ものすごい厳密に差別をする
あれほど矛盾なことはないはずなんですけど
それもあるべき姿の概念なんですね
障害者を差別すると 色が違うんだったら差別すると
しゃべる言葉違うんだったら差別すると
民衆は違うんだったら差別すると
宗教が違うんだったらそこで差別すると
年が変わったらまた差別すると
まあ何であろうとも 人はもう他人を差別する
で そこからいい結果が出てきますか？生まれてくるのは苦しみ
悩み 喧嘩 殺戮だけでしょうし
なぜそうなるんですか？矛盾は認めてないんです
あるべき姿あるんだ 頭の中に
それもすっごい矛盾なんです
例えば 差別の矛盾に気づくためには
じゃあ自分を差別されたら気持ちいいんですかと
自分に聞くんです 自分を差別されたら気持ちいいんですかと
これは気持ち悪いんです
であるならば なぜ相手を差別するんですか？だって違いますよと言うんですね
このいじめでも同じ差別でしょうし
自分いじめられたら気持ちいいんですかと
それは気持ち悪い それは認めたくない
じゃああなたはなぜ相手をいじめますか？と聞くと
まあだってその人はもう太ってるんだと
もう何か言うんです 子供の間だったら
子供のいじめだったら
大人のいじめはもっとひどいんですけど
そうやって心の中でもう決まってるんですね
無常に反対するということは
それからこの 世の中をいくら見ても
まあ世の中の無常をいくら見ても
まああまり悟るというところまでは至らないんですね
その場合も自分のことを見るんです
差別は矛盾であることは自分のことを見ればわかるし
あるべき姿という概念も
自分のことを見ればもう簡単にわかるでしょうし
そこで花は咲くは散るはということはわかりますけど
建物はもうどんどん老化して使えなくなっちゃうんだと
新しく作り直さなくちゃいけないと
それぐらいわかりますけど
その外の世界の無常っていうのは
あまり心には響かないんですね
ですから 悟りたいと思う人は
自分が無常であることを観察するんです
自分が変化するんだと
ずっと見る見るうちに
瞬間瞬間自分が変化するんだ
その自分が無常の塊であるということをわかってくると
そこでまあ仏教に言ってるこの悟りという世界が生まれる
あるいは智慧が生まれてくる
だから自分の無常を見るべきなんですね
それは仏教で内と外に分けてね
まあ内の矛盾を見る で
まあ外の矛盾を見たっても構いませんだけど
内の矛盾も外の矛盾を見て
両方の無常を見て それから無常であることにまあ悟ると
そこはもうとことん厳密に究極的に見なくちゃいけないんです
大雑把ではよくないんです
徹底的に自分の無常ということは見た方がいいんです
で 簡単に言えば 人間っていうのは今何か一つ言って
このちょっとの時間経ったところで違うことを言っちゃうでしょうに
全く違うことを言う場合もありますね
なんでしょうかね 本人
まあ明確に本人が嘘を嘘を言ってるんだとわかってるんだったら
これはそれで終わりますけど
なんのことなく それはその時
これは今というふうに平気で開き直るでしょうに
それも無常の結果なんですね
ある時は子供に遊びなさいと言って
ある時はなんで遊ぶんですか？と怒る怒ったりする
そのどっちでも本気なんです
いっぱい遊んでくださいと
またある時は遊んではいけませんと
とまた言う どちらでも本気ですけど
言ってることは全く正反対のことでしょうに
ということは その時その時
人の心も気持ちも全部変わっていくんですね
私たちはこの部屋に入った時の気持ちと今の気持ちは全く違うんです
瞬間瞬間 この自分というものは変わっていくんです
それでまあわかりやすい言葉で
だから自分というものはもう見当たらないんだと
見つからないんだと まあずっと変わっていくんだから
川のように流れていくんだから
そうやっても何もつかまること
困ることはないんだと
あるべき姿とか そんなものもないんだと
もうその瞬間 その瞬間にもう変化していくだけですよ
全部自分も 今の瞬間にいる自分は
次の瞬間ではいないんだと
そう思ったところでわかったところで
頭からすべての概念が消えて
心はすごくきれいな状態になるんです
ものすごくごちそうした状態になるんです
その人は何に対しても怒りはなくなっちゃうんです
怒る必要なくなっちゃう
欲する必要もなくなっちゃうんですね
何か瞬間で面白いことを見たんだと
次の瞬間でそれはないんだから
で そういうふうに怒りも欲も心から消えてしまう
あるいはもう智慧が現れてくると
そういうことは まあそういうことによって人間に心にこの
平安というものは生まれていきますね
それはもう悟りということなんです
それはもうはっきりした
この具体的なことであって
決してこのちょっとした宗教的なおとぎ話ではありません
なぜそれははっきりしたものかというと
無常ははっきりしているんだから
すべて組み立てている幻覚のみだから
今私が喋っているマイクロフォンというのは
マイクロフォンというものはあるわけじゃなくて
それいろいろ部品を組み立てたところで
マイクロフォンという現象が
そのマイクロフォンという働きが生まれるだけ
一つでも部品もなくなっちゃったら
それでマイクロフォンがなくなっちゃうんです
家というものはありますか？と
実体としてあるわけじゃなくて
まあ醜い汚いものをいろいろ適当に組み立てたところで
かっこいい家ができたんだと
建築材料っていうのはそんなかっこいいわけじゃないでしょうに
建築現場に見たら 見たらもう本当に見える
見られるところじゃないでしょうね
でもそういうものは まあ組み立てたところで
一時的に家というものは成り立つんです
そういうことで まあすべてはまあ一時的に成り立っている現象でありますと
そこはわかるということで
無常の結果としてそれをわかってきて
まあ心は安らぎを得られると
ですから 人間苦しんでいることは事実であるし
すべてのものは無常であることも事実であるし
そういうことでまあ解脱ということも事実なんです
で 次にこのこの前の報告書に
なんか悟りに段階あるんだとか何とか書いてあったんだけどね
私はこのあまり自慢したくなる話は言いたくないんだけど
何か仏教用語を覚えておいて
まあ知ってるんだと自慢したくなるんだけど
それとお釈迦様の教えの方法はもう違います
だからお釈迦様は無常をおっしゃったんだとかね
といって パーリ語の言葉やらサンスクリット語の言葉やらで覚えておいたっても
ほとんどもうただもう一つ喧嘩する種が生まれるだけなんです
例えば一生懸命頑張って仏教経典を覚えたとする
そうすると人と喧嘩する種が生まれるだけなんです
私は勉強しているんだと
その一言葉で逆に言ってるでしょうに
あなた方は勉強してないんだと
それで自分と他人がね
区別して差別することでしょうに
だからこの頭では覚えやすいんだからといって
あまりこの専門用語やら分析やら
そういうものにはとらわれない方がいいと思います
あまりわからない状態でいた方が
いくらかは身の安全だと思いますけどね
よく見てきたんだからね
私の人生は仏教の世界でも年取ってしまったんだだからこのなんとかなんとか勉強したり覚えておいたりして
それでもって自分がもう学問があるんだと
知識があるんだと で また余計な自分を作るんですね
自我を作っちゃうんですね
それは結局かえって逆効果なんです
例えば無常を説明してくださいと
ドゥッカを説明してくださいと言ったら
もうすぐ経典から引用して
注釈書から引用して こういうこういうことで無常ですと言う
それで聞く側はすごい知識勉強しているんだと驚くと
そういうものはあまり悟りの境というか
世界から見れば あまりというかほとんど意味がないんです
ですから この悟りのことを知りたいということだから
まあ私は本格的に悟りのことを説明しているんです
この言葉 概念というのはもう意味がないんです
なぜ概念を作るかというと
やっぱり自分と他人を区別するためなんですね
それ自体も自我なんですね
まあとにかくこの悟ることは
まあ後でお釈迦様の方
私はたくさん経典を調べましたけど
それを見事に忘れたんです
持ってくるの それは考えてたんです
いろんな経典からもうたくさん資料を調べたんです
調べて苦労して 全部書き写したりして
ページ番号から全部長いものは全部ワープロで打ってもらったりしたりして
で 整理して忘れてきたんですけどね
いつもいらっしゃる  まあ持ってこないです
持っていらっしゃらないんですか？ 今何？ 今度それはいつ持っていらっしゃる？ まあないでしょう
問題ない  まだ必要であったならば
それはまた 2 3 分で調べられます
うん  そこを持ってきたにしたっても
やっぱりそれだったら経典でどう言ってるんですか？どう言ってるんですか？というだけのことになっちゃうんですね
だから今日まあ調べる間でも考えたのは
一応悟りの 4段階目は
この昨日のこの前の話で
先月の話で説明しましたけど
もうちょっと説明しましょうと
で 段階目はこの そういうまあ段階ですけど
まあそこで意味があるかどうかちょっとわかりませんだけど
あの 私は一番古いところを今日調べたんだけど
まあそんなにどこにもそうやって段階に分けてっていうとこはないんです
それはまあ後でまあ仏教
の世界をね 概念化している途中で
いろいろ段階できたりしましたけど
1番目はね ソーターパッティというんですね
それでなんで段階になったかというと
この無常を認めること自体がいかに難しいかということなんです
違う意味で言えば 無常に納得することは自体も段階があるんだということなんです
このソートソーターパッティと読みますけど
それはソートアーパティという 2つの言葉をつなげているんですね
ソータっていうのは流れということで
アーパティっていうのは入りましたと
その言葉にはそんなにも意味あるわけじゃないんです
そこで人が初めに生まれて
初めて無常に納得したならば
それはソーターパッティと言うんです
で その人は本当にびっくりするんです
今までどこまで無知でしたかということ
で ソーターパッティになるためには
いろいろ方法で言えば
まあ思い存分お釈迦様のお教えを聞くことですね
聞いても ただ単に聞くだけでは意味がなくて
とにかくチャレンジしてチャレンジして
自分では認めたくないものは
これはなぜですかと自分に自問しながら
まあとことん理解しようとした方がいいんです
でも一つ注意しますけど
いくらチャレンジしたっても
自分がいくらまあこれだけはもう認めたくない
他の教えは認めますよというふうに気持ちに気持ちが生まれてくるかもしれません
でも いくらチャレンジしたっても
チャレンジはできないんです
最終的には まあお釈迦様がおっしゃる通りだと
認めるしか方法はないんです
だから 初めからお釈迦様だから本当のことを言ってるんだから
だから信じますって言ったらダメなの
できません 悟れません
ちょっと道が違うんです
お釈迦様おっしゃっていることは我々にわかりますか？理解できますか？納得いけますかと
そこでもう納得いける部分はもうそれで終わりし
そこで納得いかないところもいろいろあるでしょうし
そうは言うんだけど やっぱり私はこういうことでしょうとか言ったりするでしょうし
それでまあチャレンジしてみて
いろいろ試してみたところで
まあ必ずもお釈迦様がおっしゃったことには行ってしまうんです
逆らうことはできないんです
で まあそのわけなんかはね
そこはまあすごい難しい世界だからね
まあということは説明することできませんだけど
で チャレンジすると すぐこちらで仏教の側は答えを出すんです
ですから  1番目の方法というのは
やっぱりよくあの よく理解することなんですね
よく理解していくと 自然にこの悟りの機能も活動し始めるんです
それは勉強すると どんなものでも
世の中でよくよく真面目に真剣に自分で理解したい
自分で理解したいと 勉強すると
どんどんその分野について目が覚めていくでしょう
後で努力の結果で その勉強した分野の知識っていうのは
何か自分のもののようになってしまっちゃうんです
とても簡単に ですから
この勉強することも かなりこの悟りという機能を刺激するんです
で そこで真面目に勉強しなくちゃいけない
ただ単に知ってるんだったからといって
肩書き作るために勉強すると
それは真面目じゃないんですね
理解したいと試験合格したいんだからやっているんだというと
それは真面目な勉強にはならないんですね
あるいは暇があるんだから
つまらないんだから 退屈だから何かやりましょうというと
そこら辺は真面目ではありません
そうではなくて 真剣に何でしょうかと
これはと理解しようとする
そうやって仏教を勉強していくと
仏教はもう徹底的に無常であることを証明して喋っているんですね
いろんな角度から それで人間の心の悩み
苦しみやら心の煩悩やらにいっぱいあるでしょうに
怒りも欲も憎しみも嫉妬もたくさんありますからね
そういう煩悩なんかはもう
理由があって生まれるんではなくて
あなたは無知だから生まれるんですよと
そうするとさらに腹が立つんですよ
だからお釈迦様は堂々と使っている言葉というのは
愚か者という言葉なんです
堂々ともうそういう言葉で人々の知識を全部否定しちゃうんですね
愚か者に 愚か者というのは
やっぱり空っぽな人々という意味でも
何も知恵も何もないと
空っていうことで そんなこと言われると
やっぱり やっぱりちょっと機嫌が悪くなっちゃうんですね
ああいう言葉っていうのは
狙って言っている言葉なんです
もうかかってこいと 例えば
ある人が自分に対して不公平なことをしましたとすると
そうすると私は当然怒りますね
不公平なことをしましたから
で 怒ったところで もし私がお釈迦様に会ったならば
お釈迦様が言うのは あんたは
愚か者で馬鹿なのはあなたですよ
言ったら怒る たさに怒るんじゃないんですか？それで私の心の中で何をおっしゃるんですかと
不公平なことをしたのは相手でしょうと
それで不公平なことにいじめられている私がなぜバカですかと
じゃあ知識あるのは知恵のある人は向こう側ですか
そうやっていろいろ葛藤が生まれてくるんです
だからそこはまあ狙っているんです
愚か者ですよ そこで本人がいろいろ理由を言うでしょ
例えばこのケースの場合は
その人は不公平なことをしましたと
で 不公平って何でしょうかと
誰が決めたんですかと
誰かが不公平 こういう行動は不公平だと決めないと
そこで いえ この国の常識で決まっているんだと
それだったら あなたは国の常識に訴えなさいと
なぜ自分が怒るんですかと
例えば 法律で決まっていることを犯したならば
我々は法律に訴えるでしょうに
だから怒ったあなたが悪いんだと
そこは厳密に説明できませんだけど
この具体的な例はないとなかなか説明できませんだけど
で まあ例えばそれは不公平で
それは当たり前ですよと
当たり前ですってどういう意味ですかね
それだったら不公平なことも当たり前ですよと
よく考えてくださいと
その人はあなたに対して不公平なことをしたのは
その人にとってはそれは当たり前のことですよと
だから当たり前のことに怒らないでしょうに
あんたは当たり前のことをしていないんだから怒っているんだから
その人は当たり前のことをしていないんですよと
だから怒ったあんたが悪いんだと
そうやってこの人の怒りには根拠がないんだと
怒ったのは自分が何か妄想
概念 決まり 基準 あるべき姿
あるいは無常に反対する気持ちが持っているんだから
あんたはすべて無常だと知っているんだったら
そんなことにならないんだと
すべて無常だと認めていないんだから
どうせ愚か者ですよと
という結果になってしまっちゃうんです
例えば そのケースの場合も
人はいつでも常に不公平なことをするわけじゃないでしょうに
ある人は法律を犯したりする
ということは その人は常に生まれてから死ぬまで法律を犯すことで生きているんですかね
そうじゃないでしょ ある瞬間で
その人にとっては法律を犯さずいられないことになってしまった
ですから その人の立場から見れば
その瞬間でやったことは
それはその人にとっては正しいんです
時間ずれたところで間違っていると言われるだけであって
でも  そういうふうな この瞬間瞬間の出来事を見ない場合は
例えば一般的に他人に迷惑をかけるべきではありませんと
そういうことを決まったところでいろいろ苦しみが生まれてくる
そういう決まりがあっても
やっぱり全部無常だから
もうどうなることかとわかったもんじゃないと
理解すればいいんです
で 今日の経験なんですけど
で まあ我々は頭剃ってますけど
まあそれはハゲとは違うんです
まあハゲっていうのは差別用語で
みんな言われてほしくないんですね
まあ大したことないんだけど
で 今日こちらに来ると
小さな子供二人が後ろから走ってきたんです
で 走ってきて ハローハローと言うんですね
だからそこら辺子供はまあよく挨拶するんです
すごい元気でなんとかしゃべりたくて
でも私は忙しいんですね
もう相手にする時間はないんですね
で 私も手を振って笑ってあげて
まあそれに同じくハローで答えて
うん 子供たちはあ 日本語わかるんだって
もうまあ 小学生一年ぐらいかなと思いますけど
で いきなり言ったのはハゲですと
次の言葉は そこで私は時間ないんだからそうだね
しょうがないねと言っても
で そのまま行ってしまったんだけどね
で そこでじゃあこの理解次第ですね
子供たちは私をバカにしたんですかと
そうじゃないんです  子供たちは言葉知らない
こういう言葉ではなくて
こういう言葉です  まだまだ言葉を知っている世界ではないし
よく教えるのはいつでも我々は先に悪い言葉を教えるでしょうね
人を差別するけなす言葉
先に子供たちに教えるのは大人の仕事だから
だから子供は頭が剃ってるという言葉より先にハゲっていう言葉を教えられていて
まあ子供から見れば髪の毛がないんだからハゲですというぐらいのことで
まあそれでなんとか会話したいだけなんです
もし止まって止まってなれば
必ず私の頭ぐらい触ってみるだろうと思います
何回もそういうこともあったんだから
ちょっと時間があって
止まって話してあげちゃったら
まあ捕まれるんですね
そこでも頭を触ってみたくなる
一人だけ触ってみたくなっちゃったら
みんな触るんだから まあこれ大変なこと
逃げた方がいいんですからね
ですから いつでもできるだけ逃げるんですけど
で まあ頭触って終わらないんですよ
それからそれから服もおかしいんだから
それも見たくなっちゃうんです
もう切りがなくなっちゃいますけど
だからこの もし私の頭の中でハゲっていうのは人をけなす言葉だと
バカにする言葉だという概念があったならば
なんでガキのくせにと腹が立ってしまっちゃうでしょう
何の概念もなかったならば
別にどうったことはないと
そういうことで この人が怒ってしまったか
あるいは怒らなかったかと
そこで責任は怒る人になるんであって
欲を作るか作らないかということは
この人の責任なんですね
なんで欲などが生まれてくるかというと
やっぱりそれは無常に徹していることなんですね
そういうことで できるだけ仏教の話を理解して
理解して まあ自分のものにして
いくと 例えば人に言われたことに怒ってしまったと
それで構いません 怒ったところまでは
それでそれから仏教的に考えてみる
なぜ私が怒りましたかと
こういうふうに言われて
私は怒りましたと そこを自分の心を探ってみると
あ 私にとって心の中でそう言われてほしくないと
喋るんだったら もっと丁寧に
このように言葉を使って喋るべきですよと
敬語を使うべきですよと
私が思っていたんだと
私は相手のことを知らないにも関わらず
相手に条件を出しているんだと
私は知らない人にどうやって条件契約を立てられますかね
あれも自分知らない人と契約しているんで
勝手に 人と喋る場合は敬語を使って喋ってくださいとか
だからよく見るとバカバカらしいでしょうに
相手がどんな言葉使うかってのは
これ相手の能力次第のことであって
そこで何を伝わりたがってるんですかと理解すればいいでしょうし
そこで相手が本当に怒って
私に対して私をいじめるために
差別するためにわざわざと言葉を言うと
その場合 怒るべきですかね
その場合は その場合も怒るべきじゃないんです
なぜかというと あ この人は私のことをすごく嫌いが嫌がっているんだと
あ なるほど 私をいじめようとしているんだ
だからそういう言葉使ってる
そんなこと理解すればいいですね
それで そう 心の中で何もないんだよ
その時は あ あなたは怒ってるんだ
すごい面白いのでやってみてください
ものすごい面白いんです
あ あなたは怒っているんだと
だからそういうふうな
そういうことを言うんだ
なるほど よくわかりましたと
どんな結果になるかと
ものすごい面白い結果になるんです
だからそこはまあ楽しみに
後の楽しみに 皆さんは実験してみてください
どうなるか私はあまり言えません
ですから 相手が明確に私たちを貶したい
差別したいという気持ちで言葉を言っても
それはその通りに理解すればいいのです
その人が怒っていると
それに乗るか乗らないかっていうのは自分の勝手で
人を言うことに何らかに乗るんだったら
こちらは弱いでしょうね
もし乗ってしまったら
こちらは怒るでしょうね
相手の怒りに だったら悪いのは誰ですか？怒った人が悪いんです
言葉を言った人が悪くはないんです
そのように自分の心と実験しながら仏教を理解するんです
自分の心と実験するんです
威張るために勉強するんじゃなくて
インテリになるために仏教を勉強するんじゃなくて
自分の心と実験しながら仏教を勉強していくと
だいたい預流果までは悟ります
1番目預流果というのです
瞑想しなくてもできるぐらいのものなんです
お釈迦様の時代でも ただ説法を聞いただけで 1番目のステージに悟ったという人々はものすごい大勢いましたから
だから 1番目に悟る人に
仏教でもう一つの言葉を使っているんです
それはディッティサンパンノという言葉で
あのディッティっていうのは
このサンマーディッティの正見のことなんですけど
まあ正見生まれたと 物事を正しく見られるんだと
いわゆる現代日本語で言えば哲学者になったということなんです
鋭いビジョンが生まれたんだと
物事を客観的に見られるビジョンが生まれたということは
ディッティサンパンなんです
そこで内容も時々書いているので
どのような内容ですか？それはもうヤンキンジサムディダンマンサッバンタンニロードダンマンという
まあ生まれるものは消えていくんだと
生まれるものは消えていくんだというヴィシャンが自分の心に現れるんです
だから一旦目が覚めたら
またわからなくなる わからなくなったということはないでしょうに
だから この預流果に悟った人は何が違うかと
ただ頭がすごい鋭いだけなんです
鋭いと言ったっても この人と喧嘩するんじゃなくて
別に何の人々ということには全然乗らない
乗る必要ないんだから
乗っちゃったらバカだから
全然乗らない ただそれを理解するだけ
その通りに 例えばアメリカでなんとか新しい映画が出てきて
スターウォーズですか
ものすごい盛大に宣伝するんですね
であれで人々は仕事まで辞めて映画を見ようと思って並んでいるんだと
そういう宣伝をなぜするかというと
みんな乗ってほしいんですね
それで膨大な儲けをするんだと
で その 場合でもディッティサンパンナでない人がヴィシャンがない人
あ そうですか  18年ぶりですかね
やっぱり見たい見たい見たいと
なんで早く日本にこれ来ないねとかということになってしまっちゃう
そうすると あの 何て言いますか
旅行を作るんです 今 日本でやるんです
だそうです このアメリカ旅行パック
目的はスターウォーズを見ること
日本に 着陸じゃない 何て言いますか
上陸する前に見ますと
見て何かなるんですかね
1年先に見たんだから
まあ角でも尻尾でも伸びてくるんだったらいいんだけどね
それぐらいでもないでしょうし
やっぱり人いうことにすぐ乗ってしまっちゃうという
弱い性格なんですね それで恐らく見てください
2 3週間経つと あれはあまり面白くないとかね
まあどうせもう完璧なバイオレンスだから
で あれもこうではない
ああではないかと また誰か誰かが批判するでしょうね
そうすると あ 見たい見たいなと乗っていた人々は
やっぱりやめましたと
どっちですかと聞きたいんで
その場合は だから自分で物事を見ないという性格だから
すごい弱いんですね だからディッティサンパーナというのはものすごく逆にすごい強いんです
その情報を あ そういうこと
そういうこと どうですかと
見るだけでね 例えばみんな仕事をでも辞めても見るんだったら
まあそういう考え方ですよと
早く見たんだという風に
みんなちょっと何か得したような
これ優越感というんですか？ちょっと優越感という精神的な病気を喜びたがっているんだと
これ 優越感自体も差別でしょうし
病気でしょうし あ 病気だから別に不思議ではありませんと
そう自分が別に落ち着くんです
ですから このディッティサンパンナっていうのは
もう別に否定することも肯定することでもなく
物事を理解する そのまんまで
だから私の私の前の例で言ったっても
子供たちが走ってきて
もうハローハローで 次にハゲですねと言っちゃうと
これ何だと すぐ乗る人だったらなんか驚いたりする
だからそうじゃなくて
客観的にそのまんま理解すれば何のこともないんです
足音を聞こえた瞬間で
まあこれ子供の足音だともうわかる
それでこのスピードやらその感覚で
あ これは私を目掛けて来るんだっていうことももう感じちゃう
後ろから来たんだけどね
そこで一生懸命子供たちが先に喋るんだから
もう勇気必要でしょうに
あ それだったらちゃんと言葉返してあげてあげないと
まあ大人としては良くないと
それで自分が言葉返してあげると
次に返ってくる言葉っていうのはハゲっていう言葉ですから
そうすると何かすごいショックでしょうし
いい子供たちではないかと思ってもう感情を作ったならば
いきなりあんなことだったらとんでもないことに
そういうことにはならないんですね
あ この子供たちはせっかく見抜いた私の違うところは
まあ髪の毛ないことで
まあ知ってる言葉はそれだけですよと
だから時間 もし時間があったなら
それはハゲと言いませんよと
もう髪の毛は全部剃ってますよと
だから大人の責任だったらハゲではないと坊主と呼んだりともっと悪い言葉を教えてあげれば
そのようにこのこのヴィシャンが生まれたら
哲学者になったならば
別に驚くこともなく まあ乗せられて苦労することもないし
軽々く生きていられるんですね
すごく軽々く そのヴィシャンは決して消えるわけじゃないんです
全ては無常だから なんでそれだけ消えないかと
だからまあそれはね 人の足一本切断するとする
それは無常だからできます
だから無常だからそれまた生えてきますか？無常だからそのうち生えてきますよと
カニの体みたいに カニの足とかなんか取っちゃってもまた伸びてくるでしょ
だから無常だからといって
私の足を 1本切断してしまっちゃったら
まあそれで終わり もう生えてこないんですから
ですから 無常は無常ですけど
ここで足がないということは
もうそれでもう ですから
それは無常に逆らう概念ではないんです
矛盾ではないんです だから
これ知識ではないんだからね
知識は消えちゃうんです
勉強したものはもうすぐもう消えちゃうんです
でも理解したものは不思議に消えませんね
あれは無常でないという意味ではないんです
足を足を 1本なくなったところと同じなんです
なくなったんだから それからなくなった状態で
ヴィシャンが生まれたら
まあそれからまあその状態で
またバカになるということはないんです
それからこの後の時代のまあこの煩悩に煩悩を説明する場合は
あのヴィシャンと同時にこの煩悩 3つなくなるんだと
それはこのサッカーでチビチビチャーシーラブとパラマっていう煩悩なんですけど
この実体論がなくなりますね
やっぱり変化しない実体があるんだっていうことはなくなっちゃうんですね
いわゆる無常ということはわかるんだから
何も実体はないと それから疑い
一切の疑い消えるんですね
それはこの軽々しく考えればね
疑い何一つないというのは
何でも知っているということにはなりますけど
まあそういったっても別にどうったことないんだけどね
よくよく探ったらもう疑問はない
心の中に なんで心の中にいっぱい疑問がありますかね
それは物はあると思っているんだから
例えば自分は死なないと思っているでしょうし
自分が病気にならないと思っているでしょう
そう思ってはいるんだけど
病気になってしまっちゃうんですね
そうするとすごい疑問なんですね
なんで私が病気になったんですかと
ここまで気をつけて生活していたのに
これぐらい運動したのに
これぐらいもういい食べ物を食べたのに
疑問が生まれるんです
あれ 無常を認めてないんだから
いくらスポーツしても
いくらいい食べ物を食べても
いくら健康な体だったっても
病気になるとか病気になってしまっちゃいますから
それ一つも言い訳にならないんですね
で なるだけはなるんだということをわかると疑問が生まれてこないんですね
だから無常と同時に疑問消えちゃうんですね
無常を理解することと同時に
どんなものについても
それから 3番目の煩悩は
このそれはこのしきたり
習慣 そういうものにとらわれること
儀式 儀礼  宗教の世界といえば
しきたり 習慣 儀式 儀礼
それの塊だけですからね
他は何もないぐらいに何もない
ですから 宗教っていうのはしきたり
お祭り 儀礼 習慣 まあそればっかりだったら
悟る人は宗教は捨てるんです
その時からもう宗教はありません
なくなっちゃうんです
このしきたり 儀礼 習慣のこの特色っていうのは
やっぱりまずわかりやすい例で
といえば まあ病気になったら
まあ神様にお願いしたらどうですか
そこで私たちは信じるんですね
神様にお祈りすれば病気治してくれると
そうするとお祈りの仕来りはどうやってしますかと
仕来り成り立つんですね
そういうのは人間の欲望から生まれるんです
神がいるかないか 私に聞かない方がいいんです
なぜならば 私は見たことはありません
ですから いるかないかわかりません
で 私に言えるのは具体的なことだけ
人が病気になる 病気になってほしくないと人間には欲望が生まれてくる
自分の子供が病気になる
自分の子供は病気になってほしくないと
健康的でスクスクと育ってほしいという親の欲望がある
欲がある それでも病気になっちゃったんだから
これを認めたくない まあ大体お祈りする場合は
医者の医者に簡単に治らない時ですからね
医者に簡単に治る場合は全くもう無宗教ですけど
神はあっち行けと偉そうにいるんだけど
医者もこれは稀な病気ですよと言われちゃったら
もうその時に限って神様にお願いするんですね
だからヘリクツのいいところですけどね
その時神様も悪いんだからね
あんたね 今まで私のことを馬鹿にしていて
なんで今更と言ったら
人間もあれはまあちょっと冗談です
ある人は魚釣っていたんですね
そこで 大きな魚が引っかかっちゃったんです
で 引っかかってそれ引っ張ると
あまりも あの 何と言いますか
楽しくて もう神様を馬鹿にする言葉を言ったそうですね
でもなんとか言いながら魚はもう引っ張ろうとすると
魚逃げちゃったんです
逃げちゃったら神様は冗談も知りません
と言ったそうで だから得をすると神は要りませんと
損をすると必要ですよというふうな人間の信仰なんで
これはどんな宗教であろうが大体そんなもんなんです
特別にある一つの宗教を批判しているわけではなくて
人間というのはそんなもんなんです
キリスト教であろうか
イスラム教であろうか
日本人であろうが 他の国であろうがね
すごい得をしているところは
もう神も仏もあっち行けと
どんどんどんどん悪くなってくると
お願いします お願いしますと
だからそこに普遍的な事実は人間の欲があることなんですね
欲があって そこを失っちゃうと希望が生まれてくると
そこでそれは祈りによって叶ってくれるという
考え方が生まれてくる
なぜそう生まれるかというと
自分にはあるべき姿が頭にあるんです
子供は健康で育つ 大きくなるべき
成長するべきです あるべき姿なんです
会社だったらものすごく成功するべきですよと
それで損すると神様にお祈りするんだから
そのあるべき姿という概念があって
欲望があって 欲望がなかなかうまくいかない
それは無常だからなんです
これは人の希望通りに行くもんじゃないんです
会社の成長も 子供は健康的に育てることも
人の母親の希望通りに行くことでもないし
その子供の希望通りに行くことでもないんです
無常だからもうわかったもんじゃないんです
そういうことなのに みんな欲望
希望 あるべき姿 絶対こうあってほしいと自分で決まっているんだから
お祈りっていうのは成り立つのでしょ
そこで全て無常だと思った人からは
そういう仕来りの興味が消えちゃうんです
彼が悟った人が他の宗教を貶したり
馬鹿にしたりするという意味ではないんです
誰とも喧嘩しません その人は
そのその人々はなぜそういうことをやっているかっていうことをちゃんと十分理解している
で 自分が知っているのは
人間の心の苦しみなくすためには
無常であることは理解するしか道がないんだと
これ 無常に逆らっているんだから
お祭りやるんだと お盆も無常に逆らっているんだからあるんであって
そうでないとお盆がないんです
死んじゃった人も死んじゃったんだけど
お盆に戻ってくるんですね
みんな だから心の中では死んでほしくないとかね
という気持ちがあるんでしょうし
それでお盆というお祭りを成り立ちちゃうんですね
だから悟っている人から聞けば
お盆祭りやるべきかないかと
まあ楽しいんだったらやってくださいと
という答えなんです 楽しいんだったらやってくださいと
そうじゃなくて 本当にこの死んだ人が戻ってくるんですかと
わかりません そんなことは
死んだ人は戻ってくる
あなたにとって 今現在において楽しいんだったらやってくださいと
で そういう風な すごくこの軽い人間になるんですね
で このどう見たっても
このしきたりからは無常はわからないんで
例えばお数を持って 20年それを数えるんだと
何かもう三昧だなんとか言いながら
20年間それを数えていると無常に気がつくんですか？気がつくはずないでしょうに
だから いかなるしきたりであろうが
この宗教的な儀式であろうが
もう意味がないんだと
人は知るべきなのは すべては無常であることですよと
それにはお数あってもなくてもできるもんだと
だからこの悟りというのは大変なレベルなんです
もう誰も否定しません
誰とも喧嘩しません 誰も非難しません
そんなレベルじゃないんです
すごく落ち着いていて
誰のことも理解できる
簡単だから みんな喜怒と怒りだけですからね
例えばセントピーターズとか何とかという
ものすごい恐ろしいほど豪華なキャシーとかバチカンとかあるでしょうに
毎日毎日もう何百万人ほど集まるでしょう
誰でも圧倒される迫力だと思いますけどね
でも 悟った人にとっては
まあなるほど それぐらいのことで終わっちゃうんです
だから あの大きさで あの偉大なるさで
それからローマ法王についていっぱい暗示かけられて
暗示かけられて それで人間の心の中で希望に満ち溢れて
なんとか顔をほんのちょっとだけでも見たいと
彼が遠いところからこの十字架切っちゃうでしょうね
それ目に入ったら すべての祝福は自分にもう
降ってくるんだとかね
それで感激するんですよ
みんなあれを見て 涙もうボロボロと
それで幸福になるんだったら
みんな決めて みんなワチカンに行って賛美歌に参加すればいいでしょうに
当番決めて 全国全地球の人類は
でも残念ながら カトリック教の国々でもすごい貧しくて
苦しみがいっぱいあったりしてとか
戦争あったりしてとかね
それはもう耐えない 耐えないでしょうに
ですから このどういうからくりで
どういう気持ちで 人間っていうのは煩悩に操られて生きているんですか？ということを理解するんであって
あなたは悪い あなたは悪いとはもう言わないんですね
あなたは悪いという立場がもう飛んじゃっちゃうんですね
それは 1番目の悟りなんです
それで その人がなぜ 2番目の悟りやりますかと
この 2番目の悟りからはそれほど難しくはないんです
2番目の悟りはどのように説明しているかというと
まあまあ 人間だから このこの自分のものに対しては
まだまだかすかに怒りと欲があるんだと
いわゆる食べる場合は
やっぱり美味しいものを食べたいと
自分に対してまあ嫌なものは避けたいと
まだまだ自分の体に対して執着あるんですね
無常は無常ですけど やっぱり健康でいたいんだと
病気にはならないように気をつけましょうと
そうやって  身の自分の体のことを可愛がっちゃうんですね
で そこでさらにそこをそこからは瞑想しなくちゃいけないんですね
やっぱり集中してきちんと瞑想しちゃうと
もうやっぱり自分に対する執着消えちゃうんですね
で 自分に対する執着がなくなったら
自分に対して怒りも欲ももう薄くなってしまっちゃう
それは 2番目の悟りというんですね
で  3番目の悟りっていうのは
もうさらに瞑想すると
それほど瞑想自体難しくないんです
瞑想すると もう自分に対する執着はもう全部なくなっちゃうんです
それで怒りと欲 全部消えちゃうんです
それは 2番  3番目のアーナーラーミ
不還果という もう存在には戻ってこないという意味で
それでも生きているというかすかな執着が残っている
かすかではないんだけど
煩悩５つあるんですけど
で さらに瞑想すると この一番取りにくい煩悩
いわゆる生きていきたいという
いわゆるものは変化するんだけど
変化は止められないのではないかというふうな概念もありますね
だから結局どこかで正を正当化するんですね
そこは最終的にこの その気持ちさえも消えてしまうんですね
それはこの智慧の完成というんです
それでアラハッタというんですね
阿羅漢と それで何の煩悩もない
その人を体が壊れるまで生きているだけで
それで解脱なんです  そこはこの 4つの段階で
大体あんまり気にしなくてもいいと思いますけどね
その 4つの段階は 我々のチャレンジは
この無常を理解することなんですね
まあ じゃあ一応まあそのふうな 4つの段階あるんだと
もう煩悩 10種類あります
これ一つ分けて そういうものを覚えたっても
瞑想して じゃあこの煩悩をなくそうとかね
そうやって頑張ってできるものじゃないんです
だから勉強しすぎてみんな瞑想するんですね
瞑想を始めるときの高慢がついてるんです
じゃあ最初に私は戒禁取
有身見 次何でしたっけ？もうなんとか煩悩をなくしてやるぞとかね
それだけでもダメになっちゃうんです
だから事実上 大勢に人々は修行はするんだけど
わかったものは一つもないんですね
やっぱり正直で馬鹿でチャレンジしなきゃ
初めからもう頭にそんな概念叩き込んじゃったら
結局あの傲慢が生まれるだけなんです
だから私はずっと気をつけてきたのは
仏教用語 専門用語は言わないようにしましょうと
どこかでちょっとまあわかったようなわからなかった
わからなかったような
まあこんなもやもや状態で置いておきましょうと
そうするとみんな腹が立ってチャレンジするだろうと
チャレンジしたらわかるんだと
だからどうも私にも私を責めちゃうんですね
まあ専門用語でちゃんと何とか経典で何とか言ってるんではないかとかね
ということは同時に 人の悟りを
人の本当の幸福 大変なダメージ与えることなんですね
こんなにこの物事っていうのは
そのそれほど単純なじゃないんです
特に心の働きっていうのはそんな単純なものじゃないんです
だから時々みんな自分の瞑想
今どんなレベルにあるんですかと聞きたくなるんですね
ということは疑いでしょ
だったら答え明確なんです
その質問来た途端 全然何にもあんたは得ないんだと
調べなくても言えるんです
疑いを持ってるんだから
もしここに近づいてきたら
ぞろぞろと疑いが消えていくはずなんです
自分の疑いが消えちゃったら
なんで人に聞くんですかね
だからこの証明書を出してほしいとか
免許を出してほしいと
ここにおいて あなたは悟りの 1段階目に悟ったことを証明いたしますとかね
あれくらいもうインチキですよ
でも テーラワーダではそういうことはしませんだけど
自分でわかったらそれだけのことなんです
自分には疑いなければ
それで自己証明でしょうに
私は納得いったと それで言うならば
まあ私はあなたは納得したことを認めますと
バカバカらしいんじゃないですか
だから これすごくややこしくなっちゃうんです
この瞑想の世界はね この
そういうわけで このかなりの昔のお坊さんたちも修行者もものすごいダメージ受けたんです
この学問に凝ってしまって
使い方間違って それでお釈迦様いうのは
この教えをヘビにコブラに例えているんです
なぜコブラに例えたんですかというと
インドの世界のことです
インドの庶民の例えなんです
王様たちのあのエリートの例えじゃないんです
インドの一番この下の
あのカーストの一番低い人々が
あっちこっちあるカーストの人々がコブラを捕まえて人に見せて
それでいくらか食べているんです
お金もらって  そこで特別な笛ありますね
あの笛で何か音を出したりして
そこで蛇は踊っているんだと
全然蛇は踊ってないんです
あれで蛇が傘を出してくれないと
この箱を閉めている蓋ありますね
あの蓋で殴っちゃうんです
蓋でこう叩いたりすると
また蛇がもうこうやって顔を出して傘を広げるんですよ
それで笛を歌ってる人はいつでも膝をこうこうやって曲がってる
曲がっちゃうんです 呼吸に合わせて
まあ曲というほどの曲じゃないんだけど
あれ 膝こうやって動くと
この蛇の習慣があるんです
じっと相手を見ていると
目を逸らさないんです
蛇は コブラは何か見たらこれ見たまんまなんです
こうやって だからこっち見たりこっち見たりは絶対しないんです
それはその動物の習性なんです
そこで膝がこうこうこうこうこうやっちゃうと
蛇 蛇もこう やってるんですから
みんなすごいと 全然 だから動物に何か芸を教えれば
そんなかなり時間かけて教調しなくちゃいけないでしょうに
猿とかね 猿はちゃんと芸やってますけど
あれは結構時間かけて苦労して調教してるんです
蛇には何一つもないんです
捕まってきて まあ次もう催し物として出すと
まあそれはまあそういう世界だから
みんなコブラのことをよく知ってます
でもコブラっていうのは毒蛇の中で猛毒でしょ
一旦コブラに噛まれたら
まあだいたい 5 分ぐらい
しっかり噛まれたら 5 分も立たないんです
すぐ逝っちゃうんです
で それぐらいの猛毒なんですね
それはそれで置いておいて
でも正しくコブラを捕まる人がそれで幸せになりますね
あの人々はそれで生きてるんだから
蛇使いは だからコブラを正しく捕まった人が幸福になるんだという幸せやと
そこでそのたとえを見て
お釈迦様は教えをコブラにたとえて
尻尾で捕まるんじゃないんだと
尻尾に捕まったら 蛇が回ってきてもう噛むんです
噛んだら死んじゃうんです
だから仏法は 気をつけましょうと
そういうことで あの かなり神経かかりますよ
説法する時でも 間違ったら大変だと
これで量の大きさ考えちゃうと
それで人を誤解しちゃったらどうしようかと
すごい大変なことなんです
ただ 大学みたいなところで
ただもう講義みたいな感じで教えるっていうのも
ただテキストにあることを言って書いちゃえばいいんですけど
そこをそういうふうに簡単でもないんだ
とにかくこの あまりこの
心を清らかにしたいと思うならば
理解したいと思うならば
そういういちいちいろんな言葉に引っかからない方がいいと思いますけどね
引っかかっちゃうとわからなくなっちゃうんです
そこは今日説明するべきかないか
ちょっとわかりませんだけども
時間も終わりましたけど
で 今日はもう一つのポイント
まあ一応もうまあとにかくまあ一応まとめた話しますけど
このとにかくお釈迦様ははっきりおっしゃるのは
人間にはあるべき唯一の目的は解脱することなんです
他の目的っていうのはないんです
だから一応わかってもわからなくてもいいんです
生きる目的は解脱することやと
じゃあそれでもわかりませんというならば
じゃあ生きる目的は苦しみをなくすことだと
必死になって苦しむことじゃないんだと
苦しんだり悩んだりすることは
そんなのじゃないんだと
いかにしたらば どのようにすればわずかな苦しみも悩みもないんですかと
心の安らぎを得られますかと
ということにチャレンジしましょう
で 世の中では我々やっていることにはそれほど意味がないんだと
全部無常だから たとえ健康的だといってもすぐ壊れちゃうし
お金持ちになっても銀行ごとにも倒産しちゃうし
だから銀行が倒産するという
なんかまるっきり理解できない世界なんですね
でも倒産するんだから
だからこの我々は頑張ることは頑張るんだけど
子供を一生懸命育てようと頑張っちゃいますけど
途中ですぐ死んじゃうこともあるでしょうし
だからもう最終的に私は何をやって
何のために生きてきたんですかと
そういうなんか虚しい思いで死んじゃうんですね
結局頑張ってはいたんだけど
死ぬ時は自分に何もないんです
例えば立派に子供を育てたんだと本人が満足
満足します 満足するんだけど
あれも心の満足だけで
でも死にかけている自分にとっては
それは何の意味もないんですね
あるストーリーがありまして
あの これストーリーじゃないです
今日は調べた一つの経典なんですけど
まあこれヤッキニと書いてヤッキニの夜叉なんですけど
まあなんか霊ですね のの女の人
だから霊と言っちゃうよりは
どこかのものすごいこの田舎の社会的社会に入らない
人でしょうと思ったっても構いませんしね
やっぱりインドっていうのはすごい
この上下関係激しい社会だから
文化的な社会に入らなくて
森の中でまあだけ生活するとかね
そこで社会 村を作って街を作っている人々から見れば
もう部族で野蛮人で もう夜叉たちなんですね
鬼たちなんですね  そういうことかもしれませんだけど
あるお母さんが自分の子供を抱っこしてお釈迦様が説法するところに行ったんです
行ったら子供が泣いちゃうんですね
泣くと このお母さんが子供に言うことは経典として
あのあの詩で書いているんで
すごいきれいな詩なんですけど
こう言うんです 息子の名前はプナッバスなんですね
あのプナッバスよ お前泣くなと
私はお前のこと好きですけど
母は説法を聞きたいんだと
故に泣き止んでくれというふうなゲームなんです
なぜならば 説法を聞かないと私のためにはならないんだと
私の心の苦しみはなくならないんだと
ですから 子供を無視しちゃうっていうことを無視するんだけど
これはあなたのことを無視しているのは
あなたのことを嫌いわけじゃなくて
可愛いことは可愛いんだけど
あなた可愛い可愛いと言ったって
私のためにはならないんだということを言ってるんですね
あなたは可愛いには関わりないんだけど
それは私のためにはなりませんと
私のためになるのは この如来の説法ですよ
だから静かにしてくれと
だから初めは静かにしてくれ
静かにするって 我が息子
おなっぱすよ あなたのこと好きですが
あなたは私のためにならん
私の苦しみを消えるのは
如来の説法を聞いただけですよというふうな芸なんですね
それで不思議なことに息子が答えるんです
で 息子はこのその詩だから
この使っている単語が面白いんです
パーリ語で使わない単語で母を呼ぶんです
で その単語は不思議なことで
インドスリランカどこでも母に使うんです
だからテキストに載らない言葉だけなんですけど
誰でも母を呼ぶときはその言葉で
例えば我々の言葉ってのはアーリア系の言語で
インドのインド系のタミル人は全く違う言語系なんです
それでも母呼ぶ言葉は似ているんです
だからインド文化はみんな同じ言葉で母を呼んでいたでしょうと思います
その言葉 アンマという言葉なんですね
これ まあヨーロッパ系でマザーになっているのはその元なんですね
で マザーはサンスクリット語のマスという言葉から出ているんだけど
それ出ているわけじゃなくて
元はそういう元ですけど
アンマっていうのはそこから出てきたこの属語なんですね
そこでその言葉そのままそこに入れて
もう母よ 私は泣き止めました
私はあなたのためには何にもなりませんと
あなたははこの一回しかこの世の中で現れない如来の教えを聞いてくださいと聞いて
自分の幸せをつかんでください
とあの母に答えるんですね
それで母 次に仏教の結論が
あ 我が息子も説法は好きですよという喜びで
母は説法を落ち着いて聞いて
夜かに悟りましたと 悟る場合
夜かに悟るんです この 1番目
そのなぜ今日言ったんですかというと
やっぱり我が息子を大事にするよりも
自分の悟りという目的を大事にするべきということなんです
で そのストーリーからでっちでっち上げたストーリーかどうか分かりませんだけど
これスリランカの物語もありまして
おそらくでっち上げたストーリーかもしれませんだけど
でもちゃんと注釈書にあるんです
で まあ森の森と言ったって森ですからね
お坊さんたちが休んでるところで
まあ説法を始めて でお母さんが子供赤ちゃんを
抱っこして説法会に行ったんですね
行って 子供はそこに寝かせておいて
説法を聞いていると そこら辺から蛇が来て
赤ちゃんを巻いているの中に入っちゃうんですね
入って子供を噛んじゃうんです
で 母がこうやって見たんだと
見てももうそれでも噛まれたんだから
一言葉も言わない これで説法の一言葉でも落としてはいけませんと
聞き逃してはいけませんと
じっと朝まで説法を聞いていたと
そこでなんでかというと
子供は蛇に噛まれたと私は叫んじゃったら
みんな立ち上がって治療に回しちゃうんだと
そうすると説法会は台無しだと
私はすべての人々の心を清らかにする道に大変な迷惑をかけたことになるんだと
一人の人が死んじゃったっても
どうせ死ぬんだから 生まれたものは
でも 悟りの道だけは いくら理由があっても妨げてはいけないということを自分で決めて
説法だけずっと聞いていたんだと
それで朝説法終わったら
お母さんが子供はこうやって蛇に噛まれたんだけどという話になって
あんたよくもよくも言わないでいたんだ
いえ それは一向に構いませんと
ということで それだけだとストーリーはあまりにも悲しすぎだから
ストーリーの続きがあるんです
そこで彼女は 私はきちんと説法を聞いて
心は清らかになりましたと
たとえ自分の息子のことでも
怒りも悲しみも作らなかったと
そういう自分の徳の力で子供の毒をね
なくなってほしいと祈願すると祈願したところで
たちまち子供は元気になって戻ると
で そこその部分はね やっぱりあれで止まっちゃったら
あまりにも残酷で もう人は納得しませんだからね
だからそこも追加分ありますけど
でもそこでも言いたがっているのは
いかにこの悟りのチャレンジは大事かということなんです
どうしますか？まだあの今日
明日 私はいっぱい全部忘れよう忘れたんだけど
頭には残ってます ん？何？まで
ああ でも私は大丈夫ですけど
聞く側は じゃあ 4時半に始まります
ちょっと 始まります  始まります
あのそれで この頃私は何回何回も
あのお釈迦様のいろんなところにある教えをまとめてやる
全く違う言葉を借りて説明したことがありまして
皆様方は何回何回も聞いていると思いますけど
その概念を通して またもう一回
涅槃と解脱ということを悟りということを説明します
それは分かりやすく言えば
人間の概念 あるいは人間の主観という問題なんですね
で 経典では出てくるのは
この 2つの言葉が出てきます
一応 3つが出ておりましたけど
まあそういうふうな このサンニャマンニャナヴィパッサナーという言葉
3つ経典では出てきますけど
まあ一応その言葉の意味は今はちょっと言いにくいですので
後で言葉に見ます で それは概念という
一般的に言えば概念という意味なんですね
人間の問題は概念 概念とすれば涅槃ですよ
という言葉があるんです
その概念を捨てれば涅槃ということは
まあサンニャーウェーでいてニローダって
ちょっと長いですね この文章はすごい長いんです
だから要領しましょう
サッブサンカーサマとサッブーパディパティニッサッゴ
ヴィラゴ ニロードーニッバーナなんてもう長すぎる
ですからまあ皆様方専門家ではないんだから
まあまあ一応概念捨てちゃえば悟りですよと覚えといてください
それから理解 問題は理解なんですね
この概念というのは不思議なもので
事実ではありません が
不思議なんですね で 私はいつでも出す
例はバラの花 バラの花一つ見た途端
我々はきれいなものだという概念作っちゃうんです
そこでこの世の中でどんな人に聞いても
バラの花は綺麗ですか？ないんですか？で
人類みんなバラの花は綺麗ですよと言うんです
で 私は聞きたいのは 人類がバラの花は綺麗ですよと言うんだから
故にバラの花は綺麗ですというプロポジション
日本語で何と言いますか
命題 この命題が正で真理ですか？あるいは正しくないんですかと
そこ問題なんです だから私が言うのはそんなことわかりませんと
なぜならば じゃあ猫 家で飼っている猫は
バラの花はすごい綺麗な物体だと思いますか
我々バラの花を見て感じる感動を猫見て感じますかね
じゃあ猫は馬鹿ですかね
それだったらバラの花ぐらい綺麗だとわからない
この猫 バカ猫やと言えますか
じゃあ花ばっかり見かけていく蝶々は
バラの花を見て綺麗だと思いますかね？どう思いますか
で そこで蝶々はバラの花について概念を持っています
猫もバラの花について概念を持っています
人間もバラの花について概念を持っています
そちらにあるのは それぞれ勝手に作っている概念だけなんです
だから客観的なバラの花というものは
綺麗かないか どっちか
もう関係ないです そこで概念を作ったところで
我々にはそれ否定できなくなっちゃうんです
いくら私は何言ったっても
バラの花にいくら文句を言ったっても
人はそれを見たら喜びを感じるんです
その人はそれを見て喜びを感じる
そこはもう確固たる事実なんです
そこで我々はどんな世界で生きていますかというと
この主観で作る概念の世界で生きているんです
私の世界は私が作っている概念の世界
今 バラの花の例をなぜ出したかというと
それは人類みんな花は綺麗だと勘違いしていますからなんです
違う例を出してみると
主食は人間 すごくありがたがる主食はステーキですか？ご飯ですか？と
日本の方々はご飯は主食だと思っているし
ヨーロッパの人々はパンとステーキというのは主食だと思っているし
そこで日本人はご飯を見て感じるあのありがたい感じが
アメリカ人には全然生まれませんね
そこで悪いことは実際にはそういうことはないんだけど
ヨーロッパ文化の人はなんだ
この日本の食っていうのは
ほんの小さくほんのちょっとしかないし
それはもうナイフでフォークで 1口にしかしてないんではないかとかね
って言うかもしれませんよ
言ってるわけじゃないんだけど
で こちらも向こう側も
なんでパンばっかり食べて
もうでっかい肉塊ばっかり食べたりして
子豚の丸焼きも切って食べたりして
なんてなんて気持ち悪いかと
食欲もなくなっちゃうよと言うかもしれませんね
まあ実際に言ってるわけではないんだけど
そういうふうに我々は自分が作っている主観概念からすべての世界を差別して分別して区別してしまう
それで自分が正しい 正しくないという自分の尺度は自分の主観のみ
例えば バラの花の場合は
バラの花っていうのは本当に醜くて来てないんだと誰かが言ったらどうなりますね
我々はその人を馬鹿にするんです
この人おかしいんだと
あんたちょっとおかしいんじゃないんですかと
すぐ言っちゃうんです
本当はおかしいのは誰ですかね
おかしいなの そこを考えてほしいんです
そこで なぜ人間に欲と怒りからすべての煩悩生まれますか？とっても簡単ですよ
理解は この主観概念があるんだからなんです
もっとそこっぽい例を出しましょう
綺麗に和服で着物で体を飾っているお嬢さんを見て
日本の方々はものすごいかっこいいんだと
すごい可愛いんだと思う
これ 日本の女性の正装だから
それで韓国の女性は韓国風な服を着て
この胸のところに大きなリボンをつけて
長いスカートは胸から下がっているんですね
あれを見てすごい超可愛いと思いますか？正直に言ってください
そこで アフリカの森の中に生活している女性が耳に手入るぐらい大きな穴をつけて
それから唇をすごく前に伸ばして
皿を小さな木の作った皿を入れて
こうやって唇を伸ばしたりして
それから体にいろいろ葉っぱやらいろんなもので編んだ飾りいっぱいつけて
いっぱい体に色を塗っていると
あれもお嫁さんのお衣装なんですけど
皆様それを見てすごい可愛い美人だと思いますか？でも
その部族の方々にとってはそれほど美人はいませんよ
韓国の方々にすれば 日本の着物ではなくて
韓国の名前は知りませんだけど
あの服を一番可愛いと思います
で 私たちは事実だ真理だと思っているのはその主観なんです
その概念なんです それは正しいと思うんです
それでもはめられているんです
それで欲と怒りと憎しみと高慢と
劣等感とありったけの精神的な病気が生まれてくる
で いくらでも言える まあ世の中のことだから
日本の方々はとにかくヨーロッパのアメリカの真似しようとしていますね
なぜかというと 劣等感という概念があるんだからでしょう
向こうは背が高いんだと
背が高いのはかっこいいと誰が決めたんですかね
やっぱりそうやって刷り込まれるとしょうがなくなっちゃうんです
やっぱり背が高い人はかわいく映っちゃうんです
それで頑張るんですね
背を伸びるために なんで白人が人殺して歩いて歩き回っているんですかね
自分たちが一番かわいくてかっこいいと
頭がいいと思っているんですね
悪いことに猿もそう思っているんです
猿に聞けば 聞けるんだったら
猿は一番かわいくてかっこよくて頭がいいと
猿はそれで思っているんです
犬もそれなりにそう思っているんです
飼ってる猫もそうでしょうね
自分の方が偉いんだと
ただそれだけのことで
我々はどれほど苦しんでいるかと
欲やら怒りやら嫉妬やら憎しみやら劣等感やら優越感やら
いっぱい頭の中で作って
苦しんでいるでしょう
問題はその概念 正しいかないかということなんです
バラの花は綺麗ですという概念
正しいんですか？そこで人間に限ってはどうにも言えないこと
我々はハメられているんです
バラの花を見たら綺麗だと思うように
猫は面倒くさいと だから猫にとっては虫を見ると
まあ喜んで喜んで感激でいっぱいです
そこで追っかけていくんです
思い存分遊ぶんです 噛んだりして殺してはしない
ちょっと噛んだりしてまた置いておくんです
なぜならば もうもうもうなかなか出会わないんだから
もうやっぱり滅多に見つかったものだから
1発でパクッと食べちゃったらもったいないんだと
だからほんのちょっと噛んでみて
それから逃げるまで待ってるんです
こうやって逃げるとまた追っかけていって
また手で止まってもらったりして遊んでるんですね
そこで その猫が自分で外で捕まった虫を部屋に持ってきたら
家飼っている人がものすごく飛び上がっちゃって
あ 嫌だと キャーキャーと泣きわめいたりして
犬を自分の猫を追い出したり
殴ったりする 誰が正しいんですかね
本当に行儀が悪い猫だと
特にネズミとか小鳥とか捕まったら
飼い主のベッドの上に置くんだから
猫は それはそれは猫は行儀が悪いんじゃなくて
猫にとっては最高に面白いものなんです
だから猫は最高に面白いものは
自分にとっては最高にいいところに置いておくんです
我々は花を持って家で一番いいところに置いておくようなことと全く同じことなんです
そこで飼い主は自分の主観で猫を殴っちゃうんですね
だから次これから言う例も私はいつでも言うんだけど
私の二十歳頃でいたお寺の犬がすごく私に親しくなっちゃって
である日 私にプレゼントを持ってきたんですね
私のことを好きで好きで
もうものすごい状態でしたから
そこで持ってきたプレゼントは何ですかというと
ゴミ箱から道路に行って
そこでゴミ箱っていうのは暑い国だから
捨てて その時ももう臭いんです
そこででっかい骨一つ見つかっちゃって
これまたものすごく臭いんです
あまりにも臭いんだから
猫犬が これすごく喜んじゃって
ずっと走ってきて 私の部屋に来て
ベッドの真ん中にポイと置いといたんです
で 見たらすごく気持ち悪かったんだけど
とにかく自分で拾ってきたものだから
自分で持っていくだろうと思ってマットの上に置いたんです
マットの上にいたら またそれを持ってまたベッドの真ん中に置いた
それでもう 2回ぐらいやってみたんですね
あんまりあの犬に対して私は全然怒りませんし
もうものすごいもう可愛い犬でしたからね
なんてことやっても一度も怒ったことないんだから
私のことを気に入ったかもしれませんだけどね
それでまた ただまたマットの上にいたら
またベッドの上にと そこでマットの上にまた置いたら
また犬がこれ口にくわえて私の方を見て
もう体振ってる 尻尾だけではなくて
体を振って振って振って
すごくもう笑ってるんですね
どうしようもないんだから
また手を出したんですね
そこでわかったね これは私にくれてるくれるものだとわかったら
手を出したら何のことなく手に置いて自分が出て行っちゃうんです
だから 人間の立場から見れば
もうとんでもない もう気持ち悪くてしょうがないぐらいのものなんです
人が寝るベッドの上に置いちゃったら
でも犬の概念から見れば
自分一番好きな人に最高なものを探してあげてるんです
で まあそういうことで
だからどちらが事実ですかね
だからどちらでも正しいとか正しくないとか当てはまらないでしょ
犬にとっては最高 でもあの犬はもしあっち
そこへ出て いっぱいあっちこっち花が咲いてるんだから
花一本でも口にくわえてきて
私のベッドに入れたならば
私はものすごく喜んで
もうもしかするとテレビ局にも電話して
それもう放映してもらうかもしれません
こういう珍しい犬がいるんだと
でもあの犬は正直なもんで
犬から見れば花なんかはもう何でも食べられませんし
何の意味もないんです
ゴミなんです だからあの犬はバラの花一本持ってくるんではなくて
ものすごく腐ってひどい臭いを放っていた骨一本持ってきたんです
だからそこでこの我々の主観の世界
理解してください 概念の世界を理解してください
目があるならば まあ一応猫に色別能力があるかどうかはわかりませんだけど
まあ一応見える 我々にも見える
こちらにバラの花がある
猫 犬にも見えると でも見える部分はみんな同じなんです
でも私たちは受ける主観はそれぞれ違うでしょう
作る概念がそれぞれ違うでしょう
そこでインドネシアのあの裸で生活している部族の人々にしても
そのそちらの女の人がこちらに来たら
そこでその部族の男のたちもこちらにいるとすると
映る映像は同じなんです
でも我々の感覚はどうですか？そちらの感覚はどうですかと
だから目に触れるところまでは普遍的なんです
触れた瞬間から普遍的ではありません
で そこは苦しみの種 その概念
そこは大変な問題だと
そこで私たちにはその主観があるんだから
いつでも自分がいるんだと勘違いする
自分がいるんじゃなくて
へんてこりんな概念の塊があるんだということだけなんです
私たちは日本人だと思った瞬間で
日本人がいるわけじゃなくて
ある特定の偏見 偏見の概念ばっかり持っている生命体があるだけなんです
そこで他の国民を差別すると
そうやって そのどんな人でも同じことで
そういうことで我々は喧嘩する
あの人は嫌いだ あの人は好みだ
あの人はもう合わないんだとかね
例えば私があなたは私にあまり合わないんだと思って
その人に当たるでしょうに
なんでその人に会って
その人別に何かやったことはないでしょうに
その人は私に合わないのは私の主観の問題であって
それは認めないで人を殴ろうとしているんですね
人を責めようとしているんです
だから 猫がヘビを捕まえて部屋の中に持ってきたら
飼い主が猫を殴っちゃうんです
それはわかりますけど
それよりひどいでしょうね
戦争までして殺人までして殺戮でしょうに
世の中っていうのは 例えば自分が恋している女性が女性に振られたんだと悩むでしょうに
なんで悩むんですか？その女性の主観から見れば
ある時期は自分の方がタイプが良かったと
ある時期は このタイプじゃなくて
あのタイプの方がいいだと決めただけであって
だから自分のことを好きになったのもその人の勝手でしたし
自分のことを嫌いになったのもその人の勝手でしたし
これによってなんで自分が悩むんですかね
なぜ自分が悩むかと 自分の主観なんですね
この人は私のこと好きですよと
故に私のものにしたいんだと
それ 自分作った主観が破れると
そこで苦しみ 悩みが生まれてくるんです
そこで問題は じゃあ人間に主観概念なしに生きていられるかというと
絶対生きていられないんですね
ということは 生きることはただ単に苦しみだけなんです
で 救い道はどうですかというと
その過程を明確に理解して
それにとらわれないことなんです
だから我々は作る主観概念は決して絶対的な真理ではありませんと
それは全部いい加減だと
本当はいい加減でしょうに
我々は時々人を嫌になったら
いつでももう何やってても嫌で解釈するし
自分の子供は好きと思ってしまえば
子供がやっている悪いことまで好きになっちゃうでしょうね
日本のことわざもあるでしょう
なんか坊主が憎ければもう今朝まで憎いと
また女性の場合 もう一つことわざあるんですね
それ覚えてないんだけど
え？可愛いと思ったらなんか
うん だからそういう分勝手なんです
好きと思った 思ったところで
例えば自分好きと思った女性のものすごい料理失敗しましたと
それも可愛いんですね
まあいい 私はなんとかしてあげますから
嫌いになったところで何でも嫌いになる
上手に料理作っちゃったら
まあなんか偉そう 何か考えてるでしょうね
私を捕まろうと思って
だからそうやって豪華に料理作るんではないかと思っちゃうんです
そういうことで この我々作る主観っていうのは
ものすごいいい加減で勝手だから
そこを理解しておく それにとらわれないようにする
それは決して真理ではありませんと理解する
そうすると 人と何の喧嘩にもならないんです
自分の心に何の怒りも欲も生まれてこないんです
ただ これから駅まで行く場合は
それなりの概念を作る
まあ歩いて行くか バスに乗っていくかどうか
それで終わり 故に やっぱり駅までは必ずバスでしかダメですよという絶対的な真理は作りません
時間がない 早く行かなくちゃいけない
だったらバスに乗りましょうと
いえ もっと早く行かなくちゃいけない
じゃあだったらタクシー乗りましょうと
それぐらいの概念で十分生きていられるんです
でも 人間っていうのは
自分の概念にはものすごく囚われているんです
徹底的に囚われているんです
だから それだけ一番取りにくい
難しいことなんです ものすごく取りにくい
難しいことなんです だからすべては現象ですよと
仏教で堂々と平気で言っているのは
そういうことなんです
実体はないんだ 猿のメスは猿にとってはものすごい美人でしょうし
人間にとってはまあ別に
それでこの解脱というのは
そういういかなる概念にもとらわれないこと
解放されていること 事実を知っていくこと
これは目に触れた情報は
自分がこうやって解釈したんだと
耳に触れた情報はこういうふうに解釈したんだと
ただそれだけですと その解釈も時と場合によって変わっちゃうんだと
ある時は綺麗だと思った曲は
ある時は面白くないと解釈するんだから
そういう人はこの世の中で何のも束縛なく
関わることなく 対立することなく
蓮の葉っぱの上に落ちた一滴の水のように
世の中に生活するんだと
ということで まあ悟りの世界はそういうふうに
この概念ヴィパッサナーという言葉で
それからサンガっていうのは
そうやって思いという漢字が来ますから
これ概念を想ですね 思いという漢字がそうですけど
認識してイメージを作ることをですね
マニャーナっていうのは
もっと思うことをはっきりと
私はあれ綺麗だと思いますよと
私はあの人はちょっと怪しいと思いますよとかね
わざと思う 私はやっぱり世の中に神様がいるんだと思いますよと
そうやってわざわざと考えて思ったりして
さらに苦しむことはマニャーナなんです
ヴィパッサナーっていうのは
言葉をもってからくりをやっていることなんですね
まあどちらにしたっても概念作ることなんです
そういうことで 解脱っていうのはわかりますかね
ものすごい 無制限に限りなく心の自由
心に何もないんだから
この何もないことは もう無限なんですね
だから 空間の中に我々は何か物を持って置いた途端
時間制限になっちゃうんですね
例えば この水平線までずーっと広げている平らの土地があるとすると
もう三百六十度どこを見ても水平線
水平線見えるんだと そこで私たちは一個のレンガでもいいんですけど
一つ置いておくと そこでもうリミットされますね
ただそれだけのこと 概念というのはそんなもんなんです
そこで小さなハットでも
ビニールシートでハットでも作っちゃったら
この三百六十度水平線のこのモンゴル砂漠のようなところにしたってもね
一つ作っちゃったら そこは中央ものになって
それから東と西もいろいろ成り立ったりして
そこで頭の中にすべての概念が消えちゃったら
もう時間 リミット 何もなくなっちゃうんです
それはこの悟りの心なんです
じゃあ 話はそこら辺で終了させていただきます
どうもありがとうございました